[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم
وهذه العربي
دي اكشن اه في مان وجيم اتش روشن
ينطلقوا بنفس سياسي طغى عليه ملفات
اوكرانيا وايران السعوديه تؤكد وحرصها على
ضماني امن الطاقه
لانهاء اثلاتها من العقاب وتقييد صناعه
المسيره
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
كابوس الصين تحول لواقع في 2022 عدد سكان
خفض وحلم زعامه اقتصاد العالم بات محاطا
مشبوك
[موسيقى]
في التفاصيل رغم ان نهايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا تبدو بعيده المنال الا ان
التواصل بين طرفيها الاساسيين يبقى مهما
والمقصوده هنا ليس روسيا واوكرانيا وانما
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حوار بين المخابرات الروسيه والامريكيه
سيكون مفيدا وفقا وكاله تاس الروسيه اما
رئيس الاستخبارات الخارجيه سرقه نار
الشيكينه فرجح عقد اجتماعا اخر مع مدير
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليامبرز بعد لقاء سابقا عقد في نوفمبر
الماضي
اطلاق رسائلها التحذيريه اخرها اعلان وزير
الدفاع سارجي شيكو عن انه باتالي روسيا
مجموعتان جديدتان من من التسلح
الاستراتيجي والاقليمي لمواجهه اي خطر
يهدد امنها
للقوات المسلحه وهما مقاطعه موسكو وليلين
الجديده للاتحاد الروسي وذلك لتعزيز
العنصر القتاليه البحريه والقوه الفضائيه
الجويه وقوه الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
هذا على جانب الروسيه اما على الجانب
الاوكراني فبشرى دبابات تشالنجر 2
البريطانيه اعطت جرعه محفزه لاوكرانيا بعد
ان اكدت بريطانيا انها سترسل اربعه 10
دبابه من هذا النوع في غضون اسابيع وربما
ايام الاختلاف على قوتها فهي واحده من
اربع دبابات قتاليه رئيسه طورتها دول حلف
الناتو لخوض الحروب وهي العمود الفقري
لقوه الدبابات في الجيش البريطاني لكن
الخبراء العسكريين في المعهد الدولي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه قالوا ان هذا العدد
قليل بدرجه لا يمكن ان يشكل اساسا تعتمد
عليه قوه الاوكرانيه لسن هجوم مضاد صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه وفي هذا الشان عنونه
ان اوكرانيا تحتاج الى المئه دبابه على
الاقل لتحقق انجازا يذكر على الارض هذا هو
الحد الادنى اذا بالنسبه للجارديان اما
بالنسبه لصحيفه التلجراف فان الرقم
المطلوب فعليا من هو 300 دبابه وليس اقل
من ذلك خاصه وان الدبابات استعادت اهميتها
التاريخيه فهي التي قرعت جرس الحرب
العالميه الاولى بعد اربع سنوات من الجمود
وفي الحرب العالميه الثانيه لم يستطع اي
طرفا الاستغناء عنها ووافقه خبراء الحروب
البريه فان الدبابات وحدها هي التي تتمتع
بميزات لمثلث القوه الحمايه والتنقل
والاطلاق الناري وبذلك يمكنها المحافظه
على زخم المعارك لاي جيش لكن المساله ليست
فقط في امتلاك الدبابه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
فلابد من توفر التدريب الكاف عليها الى حد
الاتقان وان تكون قطع الغيار موجوده تحسبا
لاي عطل قد يواجهها في المعركه
[موسيقى]
اذا هناك اكثر من نقطه قد تقف حجر عذراء
امام استفاده اوكرانيا من هذه الدبابات
الغربيه راويه لكن على الاقل الوعود ما
تزال قائمه من الدول الحديثه
المانيا دول حلف شمال الاطلسي لعقد
اجتماعي رمشتاين المنتظر
لتجديد التعهدات ومناقشه المزيد فيما
يتعلق بالدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا بالحديث
عن اسطول الدبابات الذي تطلبه اوكرانيا
الانتقالي تركيز الحرب من السماء الى
اليابسه تحاول بولندا ان تلبي النداء
باربع 10 دبب من طراز اثنين الالمانيه
الالمانيه الصنع هذا النوع من الدبابات
موجود لدى جيوش ثلاثه عشره دوله من دول
الناتو بمجموع يزيد عن
2300 دبابه وفقه المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الاست من بينها في اللنده وكندا كلاهما
مستعدتان بالمناسبه لكن تقديمه مالي
اوكرانيا يحتاج اذنا من الحكومه الالمانيه
التي لم تتحرك تجاه ذلك بعد واكتفت بالقول
انها يجب ان لا تورد الا اذا اتفق حلفاء
اكياف الرئيسيون وخاصه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على هذا الامر حسب الخبراء فان
الجنود الاوكرانيين اذا حصلوا على ليبرد
اثنين سيحتاجون على الاقل سته اسابيع
ليجيد استخدامها بفعاليه ما بين المدفعيه
وتمهيد الطرق وحمايه الجروح وبين ما تحاول
كل دوله ان تجود بالموجود لديها فان روسيا
تجهز ردها دائما وعلى لسان المتحدثه باسم
خارجيه موسكو ماريا خروبه التي وصفت
بريطانيا بالدوله التي تدعم النازيين
الجدد وعليه
مجرد فرض عقوبات على ست وثلاثين شخصيه في
لندن من بينهم وزير الخارجيه جيمس بلي
ورئيس اركان الجيش باتريكساندرز اما
ديميستيبي المتحدث باسم الكرملين كما
ذكرنا بالامس علق قائلا انه مهما قدم
الغرب من دبابات سيتم حرقها
[موسيقى]
التي تتحدث عن خطتها لمرحله جديده من
الامداد بمعدات عسكريه اكثر تقدما
لاوكرانيا من تغيير الوضع على ارضه يجب ان
يدركوا ذلك انهم يطيلون هذه القصه فقط
ويزيدون من متاعب الدوله الاوكرانيه لن
يغير ذلك اي شيء ستستمر العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه و ستحترق تلك الدبابات مثل غيرها
وسيتم تحقيقه اهداف العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه
لكن هناك امر اخر قد يحرق الفكره برمتها
التذمر في الدول الاوروبيه من فكره تقديم
الاسلحه الثقيله لاوكرانيا وتعريض امن هذه
الدول للخطر عرب عبد الحق معها المزيد من
التفاصيل من لندن
[موسيقى]
طالما حظيه بدعم الحكومه البريطانيه لكن
خلف هذا الدعم تخوف من الجيش البريطاني من
ان المساعده العسكريه للقوات الاوكرانيه
قد تاتي على حسابك افاتهم وهو ما دفع رئيس
هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
البريطانيه الى تحذير من المضيق دون
مراجعه بخططه وزاره الدفاع التي اعلن
وزيرها بن ويلز في وقت صادق عن نيه
بريطانيا تزويد اوكرانيا باربعه 10 دبابه
من نوع تشالنجر وهو معتبره ساندرياس في
بيان المسرب انه سيضع الجيش البريطاني في
موقف اضعف امام اي تهديدات عسكريه في
المنطقه كما ان ذلك قد يجبر بريطانيا على
التخلف عن الوفاء بالالتزاماتها تجاه حلف
النيته وقد يترك ايضا فجاه في مخزون الجيش
البريطاني من معدات عسكريه
التصريحات هذه بحسب متابعين ربما محاوله
من قبل الجيش لضمان ان وزاره الدفاع
ستستبدل العتاد الممنوح لاوكرانيا
بالاضافه الى حث وزاره الخزانه لتمويل مثل
هكذا تحركات تجنبا لتراجع مستوى الجيش
البريطاني
[موسيقى]
ات مع روسيا لكنني مع ارسال الدعم العسكري
واعتقد انه قد يكون مثيرا للجدل لانه
سيقلب الموازين ويضعنا على خط المواجهه
الدعم المني ربما افضل ونحن قدمنا الدعم
المليني وايضا الولايات المتحده
نعلم انهم بحاجه الى تعمل ماليه واعتقد ان
الدعم مهم حتى لو كان رمزيا علينا
مساعدتهم وان كان الامر مثيرا للجدل لكن
مهم جدا تقدم الدعم المالي
اعتقد انه من المهم ان ندعم اوكرانيا بشكل
مطلق وخاصه الدعم العسكري اذا كانت لدينا
الموارد فعلينا ان ندعمهم
الامر
وخسائر كبيره نريد ان ينتهي الوضع القائم
وعلينا ايجاد طريقه لوقف الصراع وربما من
خلال الدبلوماسيه
فرقا في نهايه اليوم الامر غير مؤكد امام
عدد الدبابات التي يواجهونها لكنه موقف
سياسيون لاظهار التضامن ومن المهم للقيام
به حتى لو انه كان سيجعل الوضع اسوء ويدفع
الروس الى مزيد من العدوانيه
معنى من القاهره استاذ احمد علي بقى
الباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
سياسيه واستراتيجيه اهلا بك معنا يا استاذ
احمد مره جديده في العربيه 360 الجارديان
تتحدث عن حاجه اوكرانيا الى 100 دبابه على
الاقل بينما تلغراف تتحدث عن 300 دبابه اي
رقم ترى انه سيكون مناسبا لاحداث فرق على
الارض بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا
مساء الخير
الى تقديرات زي حضراتكم الذاكرت في
التقرير انه المتوفر الان او المعلن عنه
من الدبابات لن يكون كافيا لكن تقدير
العدد وفقا لما قالته الجارديان انا همم
لا اعتقد ان هو ايضا يمكن ان يكون حاسما
ولا حتى ايضا بالنسبه ذكره الجانب
الاوكراني ب 300 همم لانه تقديرات الجانب
الاوكراني ربما بتاخذه على معيار انه هناك
300 دبابه موجوده في المخازن من طراز
اليبر
انه يمكن انت تبرع عدد من الدول التي
تمتلك هذه الدبابات مقدار بمقدار 10%
وبالتالي تكون المحصله حوالي 300 دبابه
ولكن مساله ان هي تحصل على 10 كتبها 11
كتيبه بالمعيار الغربي منها زيت دبابات هل
سيكون كافيا المساله بتاخذ عليه ثلاث
اعتبارات اساسيه الاعتبار الاول اللي هو
الميدان
اداره ثاني هو رد الفعل الاعتبار الثالث
هو التشغيل او القدره التشغيليه الميدان
نحن امام خط طويل للحرب بيمتد الى حوالي
800 كم تقريبا لا اعتقد انه هذه حتى في
النقاط الساخنه على طول هذا الخط يمكن انه
300 دبابه توفر همم هذا النزقه وبالتالي
بندخل على مساله التشغيل زي ما ذكر
ايضاراته انه المهم ان يكون هناك ايضا
اسلحه معاونه
بتقوم بدور همم يعني قادره على تحقيق
الهدف المطلوب ليس فقط الدبابات وعلشان
كده ظهرت البرادلي الامريكيه وغيرها من
المدرعات وايضا وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
اعلنت انه يتم تدريب حوالي 500 عنصر من
القوات الاوكرانيه على فكره تشغيل المشترك
للاسلحه بمعنى ان الدبابه تعمل مع منظومه
الدفاع تعمل مع المركبات المدرعه المتحركه
وما الى ذلك الثالثه اهي رد الفعل ودي
نقطه مهمه لانه الامين العام له حلف
الناتو ذكر نقطه في غايه الاهميه قبل
اجتماع رمشتاين المقبل يوم الجمعه هي انه
المانيا كانت بتتخوف انه تسليم همم دبابات
استراتيجيه بهذا الشكل سوف يستفز روسيا
ربما استفزاز روسيا يخرج المساله عن الحرب
هو ذكر تحديدا من المساله الخاصه
تلجا الى السلاح اللي هو تكتك وما الى ذلك
وحاول يؤكد على انه هذا المسار يعني ليس
مقلقا وبالتالي هو بيبرر لالمانيا موقفها
في حقيقه الامر وبيمهد ايضا الاجتماع لكن
نعم اعذرني على المقاطعه سيد احمد ولكن
نود ان نستفيد من حضرتك بالعديد من النقاط
يعني السؤال الان ربما ما الذي تغير حتى
اصبحت الحاجه همم الى الدبابات ضروره ملحه
الى هذا الحد ااه لماذا مثلا ليست هناك
حاجه كبرى للصواريخ طويله المدى ام انه
الذي يحصل هو التطور طبيعي لهذه المواجهه
المباشره الان همم مرحله الدبابات
ده سؤال مهم جدا انا اعتقد ان في نوع من
تسليط الضوء على الدبابات بشكل اساسي رغم
ان احنا لما نجيء نشوف قائمه التسليح اللي
تم الاعلان عنها اليوم في مجلس العمومه
همم هيكون فيها مثلا اباتشي وهتتصلح به
صواريخ خلال الفاير وما الى ذلك وهمم
معدات اخرى وبتال مساله لا تختصر على
الدبابات لكن الفكره هي رساله للجانب
الالماني اللي حاسه على ان هو يدعم من
ناحيه اخرى او من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
تحديدا ان احنا همم تقريبا همم تم استهلاك
كل المخزون الخاص
بالدبابات السوفيتيه اللي كانت موجوده
حوالي 410 تقريبا وفقا للتقارير همم التي
يمكن الوثوق بها وبالتالي اصبح هناك حاجه
الا ان يكون هناك اللي بيحصل هنا انه بيتم
بالانتقال من التسليح على الشرقي الى
التسليح الغربي سناجد على المدى المتوسط
والطويل لانه القوات الاوكرا بتتحول الى
قوه عسكريه غربيه بشكل او باخر ودين نقطه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه للطرفين لانه روسيا
ستواجه قوى غربيه كانت بتعتمد من قبل على
سلاح همم روسي سلاح سوفيتي الان سوف تواجه
الاله الغربيه سواء على مستوى
الاله الغربيه همم اللي تزود بها اوكرانيا
الان همم هل انت توافق على الخشيه من
تعريه الجيوش الاوروبيه عبرها بمعنى
اضعافها وعدم قدرتها لاحقا على المواجهه
ان حدث اي مكروه لها بسبب انها يعني تفرغ
همم مخازنها من السلاح لدعم اوكرانيا هل
هذه المخاوف واقعيه ام انه مبالغ فيها من
معارضيه تقديم هذه المساعدات
انا في ظن الاستاذ طاهر ان هي واقعيه الى
حد كبير لانه زي ما قلت لحضرتك ان يعني
بريطانيا بتقدم 5% من امكانياتها الخاصه
باللي تشالنجر 2 اللي هي 277 دبابه تقريبا
همم لما نتكلم عن كندا او غيرها هتقدم في
حدود من خمسه ل 10% دي يعني همم هناك اصلا
طلب يعني تنامي للطلب على الاجنده الوطنيه
يعني المانيا نفسها بتتكلم على خطه تسليح
لمده 10 سنوات قادمه هتكلفها تكلفه كبيره
جدا وبالتالي هي بتحتاج لده بطبيعه الحال
بريطانيا كذلك انا اعتقد انه فرنسا عندها
مشكله اكبر في عدد الدبابات لكن هناك
احتياج بطبيعه الحال ل- اا هذه ال- ال-
يعني في تنامي في الطلب الداخلي بالنسبه
لي هذه الدول وعايضا قدرات التصنيع يعني
فيها مشكله وايضا ال- ال- اصعب من ذلك هو
الصيانه في حد ذاتها لانه لما اتعملت ورش
لل- للصيانه في بولندا اكتشفوا انه
المساله اصعب بكثير جدا من مساله ان هو
يورط المعده الجديده فيها مساله الصيانه
ومكلفه ايضا وانا اعتقد انه مدير مصنع
لوفر 2 اكد على هذه الجزئيه تحديدا انه
العمليه ستحتاج الى تعاقد خاص لعمليه
الصيانه ستحتاج الى تكلفه وتمويل
الميزانيات الانفاق العسكري بيتضاعفه ما
ننساش انه نحن امام يعني حاله في ايه في
انفاق مزدوج انه هناك التزامات او
استحقاقات تجاه موازنه الناتو بنسبه اثنين
ونصف في نفس استحقاقات اتجاه صندوق الذي
تم الاتفاق عليه من جانب القوه الاوروبيه
بعد قليل مباشره بعد هذا اللقاء عن رئيسه
مفوضيه الاوربيه
همم يعني كلامك في الوقت المناسب لنصرتنا
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ احمد علي البحث في
واحده ضد الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه في
مركز الاهرام دراسات سياسيه والاستراتيجيه
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه اخذ مساحته الوافيه
في انطلاق اعمال منتدى دافوس رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل لافاندرليين صحيح
اعلنت تقديم 3 مليارات يورو لدعم موازنه
اوكرانيا
على ما وصفته بضروره عدم روسيا من العقاب
واستمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا وفيما يتعلقوا
بالقضايا الاقتصاديه
بمحاولات وصفتها بشرسه لجذب القدرات
الصناعيه الاوروبيه الى الصين
لتفادي الاجراءات الحمائيه بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده من اجل منافسه
عادله بين الشركه
بس يا ابوي
لاوكرانيا وتقدم المساعدات لاستعاده
الطاقه والتدفئه والمياه بالاضافه الى
التحضير لجهود اعاده الاعمار على المدى
الطويل المفوضيه ستقدم ثلاثه مليارات يورو
كدفعه اولى من حزمه الدعم المالي الذي
تبلغ قيمته 18 مليارا للعام الحالي وهي
اكبر مساعده ماليه على الاطلاق دوله ثالثه
عالميه ان تحقيق السلام وانهاء معاناه
ملايين الاوكرانيين متوقفان على انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المحتله على احداث وصفها
يدينا
الحق في الحياه لذا فان النقطه الفصيله في
تحقيق السلامه تتمثل في انسحاب القوات
الروسيه من كامل اراضينا وذلك يتضمن وقف
الاعمال العدائيه والارهابيه من المحتلين
لاوكرانيا وهذا سيعيد قوه القانون الدولي
ومثاق الامم المتحده ومن وجهه نظر
الانسانيه هؤلاء لهم شعبنا في هذه الاراضي
المحتله والذين انفصلوا عن عائلاتهم
وينتظرون التحرير في الوقت الذي يعاني فيه
ملايين الناس من الخوف والقمع الروسي
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اكد انه ينبغي على العالم
سكيورتي فيما يخص الطاقه امن الطاقه عملوا
الاساسيه ما نشعر به في المملكه هو ان
استقرار الطاقه عامل اساسي لان الطاقه
حققت نجاحات
تمكنت من تحقيق توفير اسعار نفط من مستقره
يمكن بها من قبل المستهلكين والمنتجين لكن
بعض مصادر الطاقه الاخرى واجهه تحديات
كبيره جدا وارتفاعه نحن ملتزمون بما يتعلق
بذلك ايضا ملتزمون بمستقبل الطاقه النظيفه
مع الولايات المتحده لكن هذا لا يعني
بانهما تتفقان على كل شيء
يسعدلي ستيل
الشركه هذا لا يعني دائما متفق على كل شيء
احيانا نختلف بالرايه ونشك اختلفنا فيما
يتعلق بسوق النفط في النهايه نؤمن بان
موقفنا كان الصحيح عبر عن ذلك باستقرار
هذا الاستقرار لكن سيكون لدينا حوار طويل
بشكل فقط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا من البيت الابيض
يتحدث عن ان اعاده المعتقلين الامريكيين
ااا بشكل غير شرعي في ايران اولويه لنا
وسنواصل السعي لاقضاء القوات الروسيه
للمساءله عن جرائم القتل في اوكرانيا هناك
ايضا حديث عن الاعتقال غير القانوني اا
انه تستخدمها ايران كورق الضغط سياسيا وهو
امر شان كما يقول البيت الابيض
لاين قالت انها تؤيد ادراج الحرس الثوري
الايرانيه على قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه
الانسان الاساسي الاساسي
على حقوق الانسان الاساسيه باقدامهم لذا
فانما نراه امر لا يصدق وما يحدث في ايران
يحتاج رساله قويه جدا ورد فعل قوي جدا
بالتالي فاننا نتطلع بالفعل الى جوله
جديده من العقوبات وساؤيد ايضا ادراج
الحرس الثوري في القائمه لقد سمعت عده
وزراء يطلبون ذلك واعتقدوا انهم على حق
الان على انتهاكات النظام الايراني ركزت
مجله ناشونال اندرس في تقرير حديث لها على
اخطاء الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه في التعامل
مع ايران حيث اعتمرت المجال لان هذه
الاستراتيجيه تواجه ثغرات عديده سمحت
لايران بالافلاه من العقوبات عليها
بالتوازي مع عرقله عمليات تطوير الصواريخ
واشارت المجله
الى عمليه تبادل تكنولوجيا هذه الطائرات
بين ايران وشركائها ووكلاء داخل وخارج
الشرق الاوسط المجله الامريكيه استخداما
نموذج العصا والجزر
محدده بحيث يتوزع بين الضغوط القصوى التي
تتضمن التلويح بعمل عسكري وبالعقبات
الاقتصاديه وما بين الانخراط الدبلوماسيه
وتخفيف العقوبات بهدف تغيير سلوك النظام
الاخيره التي فرضتها واشنطن الشهر الجاري
على اعضائها بمنظمه القدس للطيران
والصناعات الفضائيه التابعه للحرس الثوري
تلك التي تصنع طائرات مهاجر سته التي
يعتقد بان ايران زودت بها روسيا في حرب
اوكرانيا
ربما تكون بدايه الضغط الذي تتحدث عنه من
التنسيق مع اسرائيل فاستفير الامريكي هناك
قائد القياده المركزيه الامريكيه مايكل
كوريلا بحثا مع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وفالنت تقويه التحالف ضد الاخطار
الاقليميه خاصه ايراني
تهديدات الاقليميه خاصه من النظام
الايراني الخطير والمدمر
شعبه كانت ضمن الملفات التي تمت مناقشتها
في الاجتماع
وتنضم الينا من واشنطن مراسلات العربيه
ناديه البلبيسي اهلا بك ناديه عده مواقف
للبيت الابيض يعني تظهر باخبار عاجله
بدقائق الاخيره ابرز ما جاء فيها لو سمحت
ايجاز صحفي يومي للمتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض موضوع ايراني يعود مره اخرى يمكن
في المؤتمرات السابقه انا كنت اركز
بالتحديد عن السجناء الامريكيين
الايرانيين الذين يحملون جنسيات مزدوجه
ولماذا الاداره ترفض حتى الان لقاء
عائلاتهم رغم الحاهم وحسب معلوماتي وحسب
منظمه همم طبعا غير حكوميه وهي ايه تحاول
ان ترسل رساله واسرته الفعل رساله للرئيس
بايدا تطلب منه لقاء همم العائله
الامريكيه الايرانيه لكن حتى الان لم يتم
هذا اللقاء حسب معلوماته ومن هنا ربما
جاءت موضوع او موضوع الايراني بالاجاز
الصحفي اليومي بسبب اضراب همم طبعا همم
سمعت نماذج عن الطعام ومحاوله الصحفيه اخذ
موقف اكثر وضوحا من الاداره الامريكيه عدا
هذا هناك من يرى راويه بان الاداره بشكل
عام اا تغيب عنها استراتيجيه واضحه في
التعامل مع ايران يعني منذ ان توقفت
المفاوضات في فيينا حول الملف النووي
الجميع يدرك بانه لا يوجد هناك اي بدائل
بالنسبه لهذه الاداره سواء اصفرار الرئيس
والبيت الابيض بالقول دوما بانها لن تسمح
لايران بامتلاك سلاح نووي نحن نتحدث عن
ملفات عديده ليس فقط الصواريخ البالستيه
التي طبعا تم الحصول على قرار في مجلس
الامن بانها انتهاك صارخ وكان هناك اجماع
دولي عليها دعم ايران للارهاب وزعزعت
الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط لكن الموضوع
الطائره الطائرات المسيره التي تحدثت عنها
قبل قليل وهي بالتحديد همم التي تقلق
الاداره لانه كانت تستخدمها ايران في
العراق همم قبل المشويات منها لكن الان
تزود هذه التكنولوجيا لروسيا التي
تستخدمها حسب ما تقول واشنطن
بنات تستخدم ضد المدنين المدنيين في
اوكرانيا لكن رغم هذا البعض يرى بان
الاداره تجاهلت ربما هذه التكنولوجيا التي
نوعا ما رخيصه التكلفه وبالتالي كنا
بامكان طهران توريدها لكل هذه الدول
المارقه اذا اردتي سواء كانت في كوريا
الشماليه او غيرها والان تتعامل مع روسيا
بشكل واضح لقتل المدنيين في اوكرانيا
لابد ستكون تحت ضغوط ناديه همم من حكومه
يمنيه عادت الى السلطه في اسرائيل ومن
مجلس نواب جمهوري الى اي مدى يعتقد
المراقبون او هناك مؤشرات بانه يمكن ان
ترضخ الاداره فعلا في السنتين المتبقيتين
همم الى هذه الضغوط وبالتالي تصعد اكثر من
العقوبات الطائره
العقوبات طاهر هي ربما الطريقه الامثل
التي تراها اداره رئيس
ربما اكثر نجاحا وفعاليه وتاثيرا في
التعامل مع ايران لكن هذا ما لا يريده
الغرب ولا اسرائيل اييه ولا الدول طبعا
التي تريد التجديد من سياسه واشنطن تجاه
طهران تريدها ان تلوح بالخيار العسكري
وهذا ما يركز عليه المسؤولون الاسرائيليون
عندما ياتون الى واشنطن ويلتقلون مع جيك
سولوفا وغيرهم المسؤوليه الاداره الرفعين
المستوى لانه الجميع يدرك بان ايران تعرف
تماما بان هذه الاداره تفضل الدبلوماسيه
وبالتالي عندما يقول الرئيس للناس اسمح لي
ايران بانطلاق سلاح نووي ما هي الخيارات
ما هي ال- ال- البدائل البيت الابيض دوما
عندما اسال هذا سؤال يقولون بانه الخيار
العسكري مطروح على الطاوله لكن الجميع
يدرك بان هذه الاداره لا تريد ان تستسلم
يا تريد ان تطوي كل الحروب والصراعات
الشرق الاوسط لا تريد ان تفتح حرب جديده
وبالتالي سهران بدك تماما قبل الاداره بان
اداره بيدر لن تستخدم الحل العسكري اذا
اعتقد بانه سيكون هناك تعاون اكثر ربما في
محاصره ايران خصوصا في الخليج العربي لمنع
ايصال الاسلحه طبعا للمليشيات وكن
الحوثيين او الميليشيات في العراق او
غيرها وايضا فرض عقوبات وعزل هذه
البلوماسيه يعني قبل ايام البيت الابيض
قال بانه يرحب بقرار الامم عفوا الاتحاد
الاوروبي اذا بالفعل ادرج على الحرس
الثوري على قوائم الارهاب وهي خطوه
اتخذتها اداره الرئيس ترامب السابق وابحث
عليه اداره الرئيس هناك خطوات يمكن يعني
عزل ايران دبلوماسيه واقتصاديا لكن اعتقد
بانه اسرائيل دوما تريد ان تتشدد في
استخدام الحل العسكري شكرا جزيلا لك من
واشنطن مراسلات العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
ماهر
ركبنا خطا بعدم الثبات في الطريقه التي
تعاملنا بها مع ايران والنظام الايراني
كان لدينا تغيير في الاداره الامريكيه
واعتقد ان هذا التغير الاداري يخلق الكثير
من الارتباك بين الناس فيما يتعلق
بسياستنا
الولايات المتحده تعاملت بشكل صائب مع
نظام الايراني اعتقد ان كان بامكانهم
القيام بعمل افضل
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا شخص
واحد لم يؤذيه الوقوع في فخ المقارنه بين
ميسي ومارادونا لان الامر بالنسبه اليه
محسوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لم تكن الصين تتمنى ابدا
هذه اللحظات لكنها حدثت العملاق الساعي
الى الهيمنه على الاقتصاد العالمي وازاحه
الولايات المتحده من عرشها يعاني من العقم
عدد السكان الدوله الاكبر في العالم تراجع
في 2002 2020
شوارع الصين المكتظه تشهد وتحولا تاريخيا
بتراجع عدد سكانها لاول مره منذ 60 عاما
حسب بيانات المكتب الوطني للاحصاءات فان
عدد سكان الصين انخفض العامه 2020 بنسبه
صفر فاصله 85 مقارنه بعام 2021 اي بنحوي
850,000 كذلك اظهرت بيانات مكتب الاحصاءات
الحكوميه ان البلاد سجلت العام الماضي
98,000 ولاده مقابله اكثر من 10 ملايين
وفاه وبلغ معدل المواليد العام الماضي سته
فاصله 77 مولودا لكل الف شخص انخفاض هو
اقل معدل لمواليد على الاطلاق ارقام تعكس
حجم المعضله التي وقعت فيها الصين في وقت
تواجه البلاد ازمه ديموغرافيه واقتصاديه
فالمره الاخيره التي سجلت فيها البلاد
انخفاضا في عدد سكانها عام 1960
حينها واجهت الصين اسوا مجاعه في تاريخها
الحديث
[موسيقى]
انخفاض عدد سكان الصين لاول مره منذ عقود
له اسبابه جزء كبير منه يعود لسياسه الطفل
الواحد التي فرضتها الصين بين عامي 1980 و
20 2015 رغم ان السلطات الصينيه انهت هذه
القيود عام 2016 لكنها لم تنجح في عكسي
مسار التدهور الديموغرافي لاسباب حساسه
ابرزها تكاليف التعليم والمعيشه الباهظه
التي ادت الى تجنب عديد من الصينيين ان
جاب اكثر من طفل واحد او حتى انجاب طفل
واحد من الاساس حتى مع الحوافز الماديه
المقدمه لهم
[موسيقى]
لتراجع سكاني تداعياته ايضا فخبر او قالوا
لصحيفه ذاكرتين انهم يتوقعون ان يكون ذلك
بدايه فتره طويله من الانخفاض في اعداد
مواطنيها ما يفتح المجال امام مزيد من
شيخوخه السكان وقله اعداد الشباب الفاعلين
كما ان الانخفاض السريع لاعداد السكان من
شانه ان يعرقل النمو الاقتصادي ويراكم
الضغوط على الخزينه العامه للدوله ويبقى
مستقبلها قاتما ما يجبر الحكومه الصينيه
على تغيير سياساتها الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه والخارجيه
روان حمزه العربيه
سنبقى مع الصين ومنافستها الولايات
المتحده ولكن من زاويه اخرى فكم ذكرنا
اضخم اقتصادين في العالم يتنافسان للتربع
على العرش سياسيا ليستا متفقين الى حد
بعيد لكن تجمعهما شرق التكنولوجيا حرب
الرياده تتصاعد بينهما وهناك عملاق
تكنولوجي وجد نفسه في صلب هذه الحرب ابل
فشركه الامريكيه باتت تشكل خطرا واضحا على
واشنطن والسبب ابتهلها الى بكين ولكن كيف
بدا كل هذا استعرضت صحيفه الفاينل تايمز
رؤوس اقلام عن تلك الامبراطوريه الايفونيه
تحديدا طب العوده الى عام 2007 كانت شركه
نوكيا الفلنديه التي ربما لم يخلوا بيت من
هواتفها في حينها كان لديها اكثر من 900
مليون مستخدم حول العالم ذاك العالم قد
نسميه عام نوكيا الساطع
حين هينا هيمنه على السوق وكما تشاهدون
هذا هو غلاف مجله فوربس الامريكيه في ذاك
العام
متسائله مليار مستخدم هل بامكان الجميع ان
يمسك بالهاتف الملك اذا بريق نوكيا كان في
بدايه النهايه لانه في السنه ذاتها اطلقت
ابل جهاز ايفون وقفزت شركه بشكل مفاجئ الى
المركز الثاني لافضل سلاسل التوريد
للشركات في العالم يقول باحثون للفاينال
تايمز ان قصه توهج ابل ليست بسبب ميزات
الهاتف المحمول الذي يعمل باللمس فحسب
وانما لتفقها على نوكيا في الاجهزه
والانتاج حتى قبل طرح ايفون للبيع
[موسيقى]
غريب كيف يتقلب سوق التكنولوجيا بهذه
الطريقه شركه ما تكون في القمه وبين عشيه
وضحاها
تزيحها اخرى
قيمه عالميه لكنها وضعت نفسها في قلب
التوترات الجيو السياسيه لماذا فعلى ما
دار العقد ونصف الماضيين كانت شركه ابل
ترسل وافضل مصمم المنتجات ومهندسي التصنيع
الى الصين وتدمجهم في منشات الموردين لعده
اشهر في كل مره لتضمن اموره تشغيل كافه
ايضا مليارات الدولارات على الالات
المخصصه لبناء اجهزتها وتطوير خبره متخصصه
لم يكن هنا في سوها على درايه بها في
العام 2011 حينما اصبح تيم كوك رئيسا
تنفيذ نقل انتاج شركه ابل من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى الصين وصنع قصه
نجاح لا مثيل لها لكن قد تكون غلطه الشاطر
بالف كما يقل لان امريكا تكون بذلك ضخت في
الصين ميليارات الدولارات
واستمرت في الاستثمار في بكين حتى في
السنوات الاخيره مع تصاعد المنافسه بينهما
وحوالي 95% من اجهزه ايفون ايربورت ايباد
وماكس مصنوعه في الصين بالتاكده سمعتم عن
المدينه الايفونيه انها في الصين لا في
الدوله المؤسسه وهكذا قد تكون امريكا وضعت
بين يدي الصين نقطه ضعف تدعى شركه ابل
التي تتكل بمعظمها على بي كيدز وان قال
الباحثون ان كل الكفاءات التقنيه التي
تمتلكها الصين الان ليست نتاجا لرياضه
التكنولوجيا الصينيه بل انه نتاج دخول
شركه ابل الى هناك وبناء الكفاءه التقنيه
فان هذا لا يلغي ان امريكا اسدد خدمه لي
منافستها وارتكبت خطا جوهريا في الاعتماد
عليها ريتا سليمان معها المزيد
بعد الحرب التجاريه التي اعلنها الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ضد الصين
والتي استمرت على نهجها اداره الرئيس جو
بيضه نقيفه اليوم امام مفاجاه غريبه نوعا
ما يظهرن احجامها التبادل التجاري بين
الغريمين خلال عام 2002 قد حققت قفزات
واضحه الصادرات الصينيه لامريكا تخطط
418 مليار دولار رغم كل الحديث الدائر عن
الجائحه وتحويل مسار سلاسل التوريد عن
الصين ونقل المصانع منها فان قيمه البضائع
الصينيه التي اشترتها الولايات المتحده
اعلى مما كانت عليه في اي وقت مضى كان
حققت قيمه الصادرات الى امريكيه الى الصين
في الفتره نفسها مستويات شبه قياسيه ايضا
اذا ارسلت الشركات الامريكيه ما يقرب من
109 مليارات دولار من البضائع الى الصيد
مقابل اكثر من مئه وخمسه مليارات دولار
خلال عام 2020 والمقصود هنا هو ان المي
التجاري بين بكين وواشنطن يصب في صالح
الاولى بشكل كبير وهذه النقطه بالتحديد هي
ما بنى عليه بعيدا استراتيجيته في
الاستمرار بالحرب التجاريه على الصين التي
اعلنها سلفها
الخبير الاقتصادي اهلا بك معنا دكتور مره
جديد على شاشه العربيه ااه طيب نبدا
بزاويه
الارتهان الشركات الكبرى الامريكيه للصين
لماذا وقعت الولايات المتحده بهذا الفخ
بين قوسين اذا صحى تعبير بانه همم ربما
ساعدت الصين اقتصاديا كما يقول البعض
وارتهنت بشركاتها وتكنولوجياتها الى همم
هذا العملاق لانه التكلفه للانسحاب ستكون
باهظه عليها
شكرا للاستضافه كان هنالك مصلحه مشتركه
لكلاب طرفين ذلك كان هنالك عمليه تبادل
تجاري وتصنيع
كان هناك الكثير من الانتاج
لموردي ابل في الصين لان التكلفه كانت اقل
بكثير على ابل ومن اجل ان يكون لديها
تنافسيه اكبر
وان تقلص تكاليفها لجاءت الى الصين
وبالطبع هذا الامر قد ساعد الاقتصاد
الصيني وقد وفر الكثير من الوظائف
المهيمن
للصين في سلاسل التوريد الخاصه في ابل قد
تضائل مع
السنين وخصوصا في اخر سنتين فاذا اخذنا
سنه 2019
انتاج
الموردين
الخاصين بابل والموجودين في الصين كانوا
يشكلوا 47 بالمئه في سنه 2019 بينما في
سنه 2021
انتاج الموردين الموجودين في الصين
لصالح ابل هم يشكلون فقط 36% فقامت ابل
بعمليه تنويع
والذهاب الى اكثر من مورد في اكثر من بلد
اا نعم نعرف انه في زمن العولمه
الشركات همم تقوم همم
صح التعبير
مراعاه مصالحها وكانت هناك مصلحه لابل بان
تقوم همم استيراد او ان يكون لديها الكثير
من الانتاج في الصين حيث التكلفه كبيره
وكيف يكون هنالك قدره تنافسيه اكبر مع
الشركات المنافسه بالعقل
هذا الانكماش
بعدد السكان الذي تعيشه الصين والذي راينا
اعداده معروف بانه قوه الصين هي انها مصنع
هذا العالم كل ما تنتجه الصين هو ارخص من
اي مكان اخر الى اي مدى يعني تراجع عدد
السكان وبالتالي تراجع العمر الشاب قد
يؤثر على اسعار المنتجات على همم القوه
التصنيعيه للصين وعلاقتها
هذا امر مقلق للغايه لان برايي سياسه الون
شايل البوليسي او الولد الواحد قد تم
اعتمادها لفتره طويله اكثر من اللازم لانه
لقد تم اعتمادها من سنه 1980 لغايه 2015
او 2016 اي حوالي 36 سنه
ليعود بعدها
بالسماح في ولدين 2016 وبعدها مؤخرا منذ
سنه او سنتين بثلاثه اولاد لكن الثقافه
همم
العاده الجديده بانجاب ولد واحد
وعمليه لان
الشعب الصيني همم هو مهدد بالتضاؤل بشكل
كبير لان ارقام الامم المتحده هي مقلقه
اليوم همم
عدد السكان في الصين ومليار و426 مليون
نسمه ففي سنه 2100 حسب بالامم المتحده
سيتضاءل عدد السكان الى مادونت ماء مائه
مليون شخص وهذا يعني
الصين المتوقع سابقا على الاقتصاد العالمي
ام بحكم تغيرات العصر والهيمنه
التكنولوجيه الان ربما لا يعود العنصر
العدد البشري هو الاساس اا في ذلك في ما
كان يحسب سابقا من قبل الاقتصاديين ما
رايك
العدد البشري حتى لو كان اذا صح التعبير
الويت او الحجم الذي نعطيه هو فيصبح اقل
اهميه لكن ذلك لا يمكن التقدم التكنولوجي
ان يلغي هذا العامل لان عندما تصبح
الشعوب في حاله شيخوخه اقل من ان عمل او
عنصر الشباب متواجد فيها سيكون هناك مشكله
كبيره وسيحتاج الشباب للعمل بشكل كبير اا
من اجل ان يقدم همم حياه همم اذا صح كريمه
لمنهم كبار السن ولا يجب ان ننسى ان تكلفه
الصحيه ستصبح باهظه عندما يكون اغلبيه همم
الشعب هو في حاله شيخوخه والقليل هم همم
من الشباب الذين يجب ان يقوم عمل همم من
اجل ان يوفروا الرخاء ل همم بقيه شرائح
المجتمع وبقيه الاعمار وبالتالي حتى ولو
كان العامل التكنولوجي سيقلل من اهميه ان
السكان
سيصبحون همم في حاله الشيخوخه لا يمكن ان
نلغي اهميه هذا الامر لان الانفاق سيتئثر
همم
الوظائف سيكون هنالك اذا صح التعبير خلل
اجتماعي وبنوي همم في الاقتصاد وسيؤثر
ايضا على التعامل الاجتماعي وسيكون هناك
همم ازمات كبيره
لك دكتور جهاد حكيمه الخبير الاقتصادي من
بيروت تحياتنا اليك شكرا
الصوره كانت عم تدور عليها انا واقف
بحضرتك صارت موجوده صوره فورس غلاف مجله
فوكس الامريكيه عندما تساءلت في احد
اعدادها مليار مستخدم هل بامكان الجميع ان
يمسك بالهاتف الملك تحدي
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
واضح الرياضيه للمعد واضح
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من الصومال
المشردات في الصومال وعدا لم يتحقق
بالعوده الشباب
فيديو اليوم من اوكرانيا فقد لكل دمار حدث
كان هناك بناء وقبل كل صراخ دواء كانت
هناك بهجه وقبل
كنت ملئ القلوب كانت هناك فرحه وقبل
كلوميد الانفجار ربما كانت هناك شمعه
من سيناريو لا يمكن عكسه فما حدث قد حدث
شكرا لمتابعتكم العربيه 360 وهذا صهيب
شراير معنا الليله واخبار الساعه صهيب
مساء الخير
وتابع من حيث انتهيت وما ربما كذلك عن
اعاده اعمار ربما اوكرانيا حزم من الدعم
المالي ربما ستوجه لاعاده الاعمار ولكن
بعد انتهاء الحرب شكرا
[موسيقى]